hi everyone i am very excited to present
to you the first look at the mummy now
the original mummy
uh released in 1932 was one of
universal's first great blockbusters
and it cemented the studio's reputation
as the creators of the best monster
movies in the world and i grew up
watching those classic monster films
and so it's a real privilege to be part
of this one i think the work speaks for
itself
that it is uh you know this film is
incredibly ambitious
it's thrilling it's going to be
terrifying romantic and it's also a very
beautiful movie
so the story of the mummy spans the
globe from the sweeping sands of the
middle east
through the hidden labyrinths underneath
modern day london
this film ushers in a new world of gods
and monsters and i can't wait to share
this with you and audiences everywhere
[Music]
what the hell
oh
[Music]
ah
welcome
to a new world
[Music]
of gods
and monsters
i saw her
she is real
please meet princess ahmanet
she will claim what she has been denied
[Music]
you